moving on for now though we are getting
some new details this morning about what
the fbi may have found at mar-a-lago a
file discovered at the country club home
of the former president that would be
president trump had information about
the nuclear capabilities of a foreign
government that according to the
washington post senior investigative
correspondent catherine herridge is in
washington for us with more katherine
it's uncomfortable new detail good
morning
well good morning tony national security
and nuclear experts told cbs news if the
intelligence was compromised it has the
potential to damage collection methods
to even burn sources the analysts who do
not have first-hand knowledge of the
mar-a-lago record set intelligence
describing a foreign government's
military defenses including its nuclear
capabilities can reveal fragile
collection methods such as human sources
electronic surveillance and spy
satellite technology in the intelligence
world this highly classified information
is called compartmented intelligence
because the distribution is limited
access highly restricted and on a
need-to-know basis such as the president
a limited number of cabinet secretaries
and those directly running an operation
the experts said it will be important to
know if the military defense
intelligence is about an adversary or a
friendly nation because gathering on our
partners is done but considered
extremely sensitive the washington post
cites people familiar with the matter
which cbs news has been unable to
independently verify the former
president spokesperson accused the post
of coordinating with the biden
administration in quote never-ending
leaks vlad
all right catherine thank you very much